thank
you um you know I forgot what I was to
say you know what what you said is
really important I mean I sat on the
advisory committee for a long and the OT
Advisory Board and um you kind of feel
like you're on an island and and I I we
I have not talked to people in the
medical board yet but I would bet that
they would might actually appreciate
everything you just
said I think the medical board does a
great job I think the providers uh in
the state are doing a great job I think
most hospitals and he Healthcare systems
are doing a great job there are outliers
that we have to be able to identify if
is all I'm saying and I think the way we
can get at it is through a committee
that will be able to understand the
process and maybe make recommendations
maybe not but if there's if the only
recommendation that came out of it was
the um Board of Medicine is underst
staffed and cannot handle the
information that is given to them that
would be one thing if the reporting from
a Health Care provider's office or an
institution or a hospital whatever is
inadequate we have to understand and
what is it that the bare minimum has to
be reported and by whom from these
institutions maybe not from the CEO's
office not in the SE Suite maybe it
comes from the medical review board in
the hospital maybe it comes from you
know the um Quality review Boards of any
hospital or practice but we we have to
better understand how the process
happens how the information is garnered
in the in the healthare setting and then
given to the Board of Medicine to make
determinations and also to assist them
in understanding the information in
getting to the bottom line and there
therefore recommendations to the
oversight HHS oversight could then
possibly be
made so that would be my two cents I I
totally agree and I I don't know what
the process of this is but about making
motions as a committee do we need to
make motions or do we just say that
that's
our
that oh so there's a note that comes out
of
this
folder
okay um one thing having the idea of a
an thing 15 minutes before the uh full
committee meeting I think represented
McDonald's already planned one based on
so it we'd have to be careful about that
otherwise um and that one that's on the
organ
donation I would say at this point in
time given the gravity of what can
happen with an all I don't disagree that
most of it probably works fine but we're
dealing with what happens when we have
outliers and what's the process to
identify an outlier and what's the
process to report that and right now I
don't understand it well enough to begin
to understand what needs to be done to
have somebody from an agency come and
saying they solved the problem
everything's fine I'd like to have the
committee Explore More into that and
understanding okay what did you do do
you need more resources to the Board of
Medicine um what's the reporting
requirements and that's what I'm trying
to get to I think the committee can
tease those things out that you would
not have
otherwise I I would fully agree and
support that because I also think that
regardless of comes out of oplc you know
testimony if they were to present to us
I I still think we would want to have a
committee that can say okay thank you
for that you've done a great job you've
updated us but we still need to
understand better the processes within
the hospital in the reporting system the
Board of Medicine their Staffing what do
they need for support etc etc it's going
to Sunset by this 322 in 2 years anyway
but at least maybe we'll get some
information and again my concern is just
bottom line patient quality care and um
and I I I think like I said I I think
that most providers most Healthcare
organizations the Board of Medicine
everybody involved taking care of
patients in this state does a great job
I just want to protect this from the
outlier and also to bring back trust for
the public to healthc care and to the
Board of
Medicine if I could add a comment I I
think one of the comments that I've
heard over and over again whether it's
deserved or not was a lack of faith in
the Board of Medicine and if nothing
else maybe this can help improve their
standing and I I was kind of taken aback
by that to be honest but this was coming
from not Medical people within our own
committee so um so would our
recommendation as a group then be that
we would still want to consider the
committee as a recommendation from
322 and it would be nice to hear from
oplc that gives us a little bit more
information but I still feel that a
committee um as structured two you know
Senators three House of Representatives
would be very good to bring in the
appropriate people from hospital from
provid ERS from Board of Medicine and
then come up with an understanding of
process and any recommendations that
follow after
that the other thing too is that if it
leaves the house with ond to pass and
comes out of the house it's also going
to have a full Hearing in the Senate M
so we're going to have opportunities at
a point in time to have the Senate weigh
on it and have hearing at the Senate
level and if we hear all the things that
we should hear and it does look like
it's going the right direction the the
Senate at that point in time could vote
to itl it right so I think at this point
in time to kill it this early in its
journey is premature I
agree I
agree that makes sense to me too because
if it turns out to really be unnecessary
it there there are plenty of places time
way
so do we need to oh go ahead so I don't
sure exactly what the process and what
the procedure is going to be but there a
couple of things I wanted to amend in
the bill I would like to consider four
members of the
house two from the HHS possibly two from
Ed
Edna and one from each party to be sure
this is nonpartisan or at least
bipartisan two members from the Senate
but the other thing I picked up on
was under line 15 where it says
Association of nurses it should be
Association in my opinion of nurse
practitioners they're the ones I think
that really um should be at the table
versus a nothing is a registered nurse
but they're not at the same level as far
as hospital privileges and so forth
practitioner you can do both yeah I
think nurses in the hospital
they're the ones you ask
ask we all know what they do
so no I I agree with you totally
and I think this is what I'm struggling
with because this case was a hospital
issue but we're not just dealing with
Hospital issues um so I think I mean the
only thing I'm struggling with as a
husband of a nurse practitioner and I
practitioners I mean one thing I've
learned from this process is not
overburdening committees with numbers
and um um I mean do we need to include
Pas then too that's what I'm getting at
because there's a huge you know I look
at the difference I see represent Nel is
the fact that a nurse practitioner does
have independent practice and therefore
the oversight is not there like you do
with a pa pa does have position
oversight um so they for they're like
each other but they are fundamentally
different
but aren't they they aren't regulated by
the Board of Medicine they're regulated
by the nursing association correct but
so I don't mean that you wouldn't value
their input but it is a different I mean
it is different as opposed to Pas who
are supervised directly by us corre but
back the same thing if you're on Private
Practice sometimes this is hospital
right now but I think it needs to be
broader than just the hospital and
therefore if you have nurse
practitioners out there on the own then
how do that get pulled into it because
it's a separate type of practice setting
I do agree with what you're saying about
the nurse inside of the hospital they
probably know more about what's going on
than anyone else but I want to be sure
we don't somehow exclude the nurse
practitioners in in the process because
ultimately there could be issues there
as well so so my question would be then
uh because obviously you don't have a
draft of that would be we'd want to just
pass this on to the full committee and
then you could draft a a an amendment to
be considered at the committee so today
all we need to do really is just yeah
what and what were those recommendations
or those changes that you wanted I saw I
saw uh well four house members four
house members two from HHS and
EA two from Edna because that's who the
boards are one from each party majority
and minority and then in the Senate be
two members from the Senate again one
from each party try to make this truly
bipartison right what with each of the
two committees um Health Human Services
and LLY Affairs yeah and and two from
executive departments Administration one
HHS person would be Democrat one a
republican is
that gota the same thing with the Edna
sure and I'm if you want to leave it
with the nursing association I think
they definitely have a role here um but
I think also npor should be somehow
identified as well
um right but if you leave it with the
nursing association then they could pick
which they
want they could that's true but I would
be concerned that they would not pick a
nurse
practitioner I think you are totally
correct and I think you do need to
yeah I know that the that medicine in
general has has you know we have to be
careful that it's not looking like we're
going to try to regulate nurse
practitioners because that's U that's
been
a
represent Palmer that's definitely been
a point of contention I think if we
include the nurse practition we can
minimize that as well so my question is
with those changes which are not really
substantively you know big changes those
changes that are not substantively you
know major changes just making a change
in the makeup of the committee can that
just go right to the committee for
Action it doesn't have to have another
PLL public hearing or anything like that
great
you so if I put through an amendment to
322 with the changes I talked
about can I ask you folks to co-sponsor
the
amendment thank
you
sure
322 so I will call this hearing closed
so then I need to know what I need to do
so I just fill this form out that we
basically said autop pass do I need to
put any substantive discussion as to why
we want why we feel the way we do or
just circle
there
all right and then um the amendment part
do I need to put that in here too um no
that it
was
okay and then I fill this I'll give it
to
right